no but if um if a guy if a guy has
because if she chooses to have
unprotected sex with him yeah she's
making that choice but he's making okay
but let's say she does who is the who is
the choice to take the plan b pill
hold who has the power to yeah she does
she that's why who is who has the power
to get an abortion
it is her yeah it's true does the man
have any say in that i agree so that's
what i say it's it's her own fault you
could you could okay let's say let's say
one you can track your cycle there's
only like five days
in a month or whatever that you're
really likely to get pregnant i know it
can happen outside of that yeah okay but
you can track your cycle
that doesn't work what can you do a
condom okay
if that doesn't work you can get a plan
b pill
if that doesn't work next time around
get an iud so if that doesn't work no no
i'm not done okay if that doesn't work
and you get pregnant you can go get an
abortion
the men have no say in this not i know
so